today on the matt welsh show new york
city attempts to lure all of the
groomers who are upset about florida's
anti-grooming law meanwhile the sexual
indoctrinators in the public school
system continue to out themselves in
droves another benefit of the florida
law also d.c authorities continue to
refuse to investigate the murder of five
fully developed infants in the city and
you heard about corn pop now biden has a
story to share about big mama plus oreos
go woken in our daily cancellation
madonna has apparently turned into some
kind of lizard but it's better than
looking old she thinks we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know dealing with finances might not
be an enjoyable experience but
on the other hand seeing my expenses
decrease and my savings increase well
that is an enjoyable and rewarding
experience and these days uh it's also
necessary for so many people to save all
the money that you can i've been saving
hundreds a month after refinancing my
mortgage with american financing since
working with them i've been able to put
more money away towards family vacations
and other financial goals that we have
with interest rates being so low it
would be a mistake i think to not give
them a call what are you waiting for
take advantage of a free mortgage review
where a salary based mortgage consultant
will help guide you through all the
different refinancing options available
to you there's no pressure no obligation
you're not going to be on the hook all
you got to do is just have a simple
conversation about custom loans that
will help you achieve your goals faster
and if you start soon you can skip up to
two payments and you may close in as
fast as 10 days all you got to do is
call 866 569 4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 and mls consumeraccess.org
last month an astrophysicist at nasa
named alex howe published a paper
proposing an ambitious and possibly
insane idea to build human colonies on
venus
of course temperatures on the planet
routinely make it up to about 800
degrees with 200 mile per hour winds and
a poisonous atmosphere 95 comprised of
carbon dioxide seems like a rather
hospitable place for human life but
howe's plan anyway is still to construct
giant floating rafts that would hover
far above the most toxic part of the
planet
there would be big machines converting
the upper layer of the atmosphere into
breathable air and you would just kind
of live up there on the big raft
drifting above the hellish abyss hoping
that you know the machines don't
malfunction or run out of gas
given especially the nearest gas station
would be approximately 75 million miles
away
now i bring this up because i think it
could be a great alternative for the
people in our country who are so
disturbed and mortified by the
anti-groomer movement in florida and
across the country
perhaps for the people who adamantly
oppose efforts to protect children and
who openly desire to turn little
five-year-olds into genderqueer
bisexuals it would ultimately be best if
they kind of form their own settlements
as far away from the rest of human
civilization as possible
venus is basically hell already so it
seems like an appropriate location and
it's where they're all headed anyway
when it comes down to it so and where
the yeah we could just cut to the chase
and they could hurl themselves directly
into the sun that would be a
more than acceptable compromise i think
now
until we have the technology and
logistical capability though to explore
those alternatives i think the one
offered this week by mayor eric adams in
new york
might be the best option
so the mayor's office posted this on
monday on twitter it says breaking
new york city mayor announces a new
digital billboard campaign in five
florida markets denouncing the hateful
don't say gay law and inviting
floridians to move to new york
and as you can see the billboard says
that uh it says the word gay over and
over again
and
it invites groomers to come to the city
where you can say whatever you want
of course that's not a universal
invitation i mean not anybody can say
whatever they want for example they
certainly don't want you to come to new
york city and say that men can't get
pregnant or women don't have penises
they don't want to hear that
there are many basic truths that these
latter-day flat earthers do not want you
to say in new york city or anywhere else
no they're specifically recruiting the
sorts of people
who want to say sexually confusing
things to preschoolers that's what
they're going after
new york by the way can't stop homeless
drug addicts from randomly tossing women
in front of trains on the subway
but rather than focus on that problem or
all the drugs all the crime and
everything they're busy running a
recruitment drive for pedophiles
here's the mayor himself making his
sales pitch to the groomers of florida
listen
that's what this movement of don't say
gay is about
this political
showmanship
of attempting to demonize a particular
group or community is unacceptable and
we are going to loudly
show our support and say to those who
are living in florida listen we want you
here in new york
you know we want you right here in new
york city and it's more than just saying
that it's also standing up and aligning
ourselves with the men and women of the
lgbtq plus community and stating that we
are in unisons with you and your right
to
have
self-identification your right to be
live the lifestyle and live the lives
that you choose to live
you know i love this idea personally
adam says his appeal is to lgbt people
but that's that's not the case the bill
in florida has nothing at all to do with
lgbt people at all it very specifically
targets the sexual indoctrination of
young children
and forbids any school employee
gay or straight or whatever else
from engaging in such activities
so it is those people those who want to
sexually indoctrinate children who adams
is really trying to entice here and
sounds great to me in fact as a
tennessean i'd like to personally invite
the mayor to launch a similar billboard
campaign in my state in order to lure
our groomers to new york i think it's
great
the normal people of america are fully
on board with any plan to round these
people up consolidate them and get them
all in one place
after all at this point new york city
really isn't much different from venus
from a sort of quality of life
perspective anyway
now
this is one of the best things i think
about the legislation it has had the
probably unintended effect of flushing
the groomers out into the open
the aftermath of this bill is it's like
the sidewalk after a rainstorm all the
worms have slithered out of their holes
you can practically smell them they're
announcing themselves to the world
like for example um here's this this
woman here a preschool drag king who's
very upset about the law let's listen to
her
so because i've been getting this
question a lot lately i am going to use
this space to answer it
and that is as a preschool teacher a
drag king and as a member of the lgbtq
community
how
do i feel about the nude legislations
for like the don't say gay bill or
the reporting of transgender kids
and while i don't see things like that
too much in preschool
my opinion on it is
that i don't care what the government
tells me to do
i am going to do what i think is best
for the health
and safety
and that includes mental health and
safety and emotional health and safety
of my kids i will never let any child
come through my classroom feeling
unloved or ashamed for who they are you
know i don't know what's more concerning
that she's out of breath from simply
talking or that she wants to talk to
four-year-olds about their sexuality on
second thought the latter is definitely
the most concerning the former is her
own health issue that i hope she gets
checked out but
she as with many other teachers has you
know made herself known
all for the best i think
same goes for this guy he's a fifth
grade teacher who's very excited to make
this announcement listen
i ended up telling the my students that
i was gay
and how it came up was one of the
students
i was like you know my mom thinks that
you're gay because of your voice and i'm
like maybe maybe not so
so they were asking me if i was because
i kind of alluded that i was
so i kind of let them wonder and ponder
on it
and
i have like
um you know like the lgbt
uh promotional like uh this is a safe
community kind of stuff
the rainbow stuff all up in my room
and i told them i'm like if you look
around the room that should give you an
answer to your question so
i did officially tell them
um
they of course went berserk so instead
of teaching social studies today
um they just asked me a whole bunch of
questions about being gay so i think it
was pretty well
so instead of teaching the subject that
he was hired to teach they instead the
class instead discussed his sexuality
for 45 minutes
now he tries to pawn responsibility for
this distraction off onto the kids
themselves claiming that one of them
asked him about his sexuality makes you
wonder about the environment in that
classroom that they all felt it
appropriate to talk about in the first
place but even if that's true the
appropriate response from an adult is to
remind the student that they're in class
to learn about social studies and
conversations should be relegated to
that topic not his personal life
but of course there's a reason that the
students felt it appropriate to bring
this up if they did in fact bring it up
the teacher admits that he has gay
paraphernalia draped all over the
classroom
now if he had star wars posters plaster
all over the walls and a student asked
him about star wars it wouldn't be fair
to say that the student brought up the
subject he brought it up by making his
whole classroom into a star wars shrine
just as in this case he had made his
classroom into a shrine to his own
sexual proclivities and speaking of
shrines by the way i continue to have to
observe that
if he had christian images all over his
classroom crucifixes and everything else
and signs
calling
students to accept jesus christ as their
lord and savior that he'd be fired for
that that would be considered a
constitutional violation of the
separation of church and state
well how is this any different
you know the pride flag is his religion
but he puts it up there he's just
waiting for one of the children to
notice all the stuff so that he'd have
an excuse to spend an entire class
talking about it talking about himself
and now he's announced it to the world
and offered this public confession i
think it's all for the best
now a teacher in kansas meanwhile has
come up with what he believes is a
strong defense of sexually
indoctrinating kindergartners
you got to listen to this argument to
believe it although even if you listen
to it you won't believe it but um here
it is listen
they've been exposed to information
they're ready to learn about it whether
you think they are not
and the research says that there is no
age too young to talk about pretty much
anything if they know about it
they're ready to learn about
right so there is no
you know what we think is always age
appropriate it is if they don't know
about it
if they haven't been exposed to it then
yeah you can
give them time to develop
but once they're exposed to it and
social media is going to do it
right i know some kindergarteners in
this school with cell phones
mine had a cell phone
and so
they they get access to information they
can they can learn quickly the world is
teaching them faster than probably you
are and so
the extent to which we can have
conversations with parents around
um how do we want to um approach talking
about
lgbtq plus because
they're students as early as
kindergarten who are identifying
um as uh non-gender conforming uh
non-binary
um
that are uh transgender um
and so because they're in our school
they're in our classrooms
then that becomes a responsibility on
the adults to say okay
[Music]
i have a student who identifies this way
and so it's my responsibility to make
sure the classroom invites inviting to
to them
just like it is to someone who might be
um asian laotian
korean
african
whatever the identity is
the research says there's no age too
young to talk about pretty much anything
he says there are kindergarteners who
are gender non-conforming non-binary and
transgender he claims
the world has already exposed them to
this stuff anyway he declares
every part of this is false backwards
contrary to common sense and moral
decency there is no age i mean what
there's almost like there's no age
too young to talk about anything
so a child's brain from birth is capable
of processing and understanding anything
at all
okay well then why aren't we giving
calculus lessons in preschool why don't
we have graphic historical lectures
about the holocaust in kindergarten
complete with photographs from auschwitz
no age is too young right
and if children aren't too young for any
concept
then why do we have age of consent laws
i mean consent is is mental it's a
psychological thing
it's a psychological assent to
engage in a certain activity that's what
consent is
our current laws assume that children do
not have the psychological and mental
formation required to give fully
informed consent which they don't
but according to his logic should we get
rid of that too
well it's a rhetorical question no need
to answer it i already know the answer
the answer from the groomers at least to
the last question is yes we should get
rid of it
now that might not be their explicit
verbal answer right now but they'll get
there
the current controversy is pushing them
ever faster and further to that final
mask off moment
these people what you have to understand
is that they're at war with
not just children but childhood itself
as a concept
they despise innocence and purity in any
form
especially the innocence and purity of
childhood
they see it as something that has to be
destroyed consumed obliterated
and replaced
with something else something that's
broken and damaged
as broken and damaged as themselves
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know we've been talking a lot lately
about inflation and here's one thing
that you should know when inflation is
at seven percent like it is now that
paper money in your wallet is losing
value fast and you could just feel your
wallet getting lighter and lighter if
you have any cash in it to begin with
which i never do but also we know that
russia's full-scale invasion of ukraine
has now worsened the market's slow
decline it's just bad on top of bad but
today an ounce of gold is worth 1900 it
was worth about 300 an ounce of 2 000.
i've been telling you for a while now
that you can buy gold from birch gold
it's your hedge against inflation but
did you know there's another way to
hedge your guns inflation that is buy
silver from birch gold
silver is also considered a real money
and historically speaking it's extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal that's in high demand for
everything from electric cars to solar
panels demand is only going to rise and
some analysts suggest that there's an
unusual dislocation in price that may
present very real opportunities for
silver to rally over the next two years
regardless silver like gold is never
going to zero so call birch gold they
are the only company i trust don't wait
start diversifying text walsh to 98 98
98 to get a free info kind of buying
gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account there's no obligation to get
this info text walsh to 98.98 to get
your free info kit now
you notice the uh contradiction too by
the way i mean there's contradictions
all over the place when they get into
this
into this uh stuff about the so-called
don't say gay bill but they also
proclaim
that um on on one hand you know nobody's
talking about this stuff in the schools
anyway so it's it's irrelevant it's not
a conversation that comes up
but then we also hear from
that teacher
a minute ago he says that well we've got
we have gender non-conforming
and transgender kindergartners
now
that
simply did not exist prior to five years
ago
and literally anyone who went to
kindergarten
um
up until a few years ago can attest to
this
i mean just try to find one adult today
and ask them did you have any
transgenders in your kindergarten class
with you the answer is going to be no
none
and now according to this teacher
they're all over the place
i actually believe that i mean i believe
it's now of course in in reality there
are no transgender kindergartners that
can't actually exist but there are many
kindergarteners who are confused about
their gender um
and so on on one hand they tell us that
well we've got all these quote trans
kindergartners but on the other hand we
don't talk about it in in the class so
this is a non-issue well how did we end
up with so many if you don't talk about
it
this is precisely how we've ended up in
this position
where we have all these kids who are
confused in the first place because you
are indoctrinating them into it at a
young age
and it's a self-perpetuating thing right
it's a circular kind of logic to it
where they say that uh well we don't
talk about it but they've aren't but
they've already been exposed so we might
as well talk about it and then we talk
about it which means that more are
exposed and well they've been exposed so
we might as well talk about it around
and around we go
now a little bit more on this the white
house yesterday was um was asked by the
only real reporter in the room at these
white house briefings peter ducey about
the um
the bill and and uh whether or not
specifically i think it's a very good
question i'm glad that peter ducey asked
it of course he wasn't going to get an
answer about it but you have to try
anyway uh he wants to know does the
white house think
that kindergartners should actually be
taught about things like transgenderism
and here is the non-response he was
given
what about this new law in florida at
what age does the white house think that
students should be taught about sexual
orientation and gender identity
well i would say uh first of all peter
we have spoken to
the don't say gay bill in the past i
believe is what you're referring to and
made clear that
as we look at this
this
this law
what we think it's a reflection of is
politicians in florida propagating
misinformed hateful policies that do
absolutely nothing to address uh the
real issues uh the department of
education is well positioned and ready
to evaluate
what to do next and when and its
implementation whether it's this
implementation violates federal civil
rights law
but i would note that parents across the
country
are looking to
um you know
national state and district leaders to
support our nation's students to ensure
that
kids are treated equally in schools and
that is certainly not this is not a
reflection of that and so just the last
one it so if you guys oppose this law
that
bans classroom instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k-3
does white house support that kind of
classroom instruction before
kindergarten do you have examples of
schools in uh florida that are teaching
kindergarteners about sex education i'm
just asking for the president i think
that's a i think that's a relevant
question because i think this is a
politically charged
harsh law that is putting
parents and lgbtq plus kids in a very
difficult uh a heartbreaking
circumstance and so i actually think
that's a pretty relevant question
well to to completely contradictory
points here that she gives that makes no
sense so on one hand it's an attack on
human rights and this is a horrible
harsh thing that is causing so much
trauma to lgbt people across the florida
and across the entire world
so that's on one hand on the other hand
um it is outlawing something that never
happens anyway she claims so then why
are you so upset about it if it's true
that it's outlawing something that never
happens anyway then i mean you can argue
uh you can make a similar argument to
the one that i made against the
anti-lynching law which is that this is
an unnecessary law it's all virtue
signaling whatever so you can you can
make that law you can make that argument
it would be a false argument in this
case it was true when it comes to the
anti-lynching law
but those are two different arguments
how can it be both how can it be a law
that on one hand does nothing and on the
other hand infringes on civil rights
if it's infringing on civil rights then
it must be doing something and then you
have to ask what exactly is it doing
because all the law does according to
the language is prohibit classroom
instruction on these topics from k
through third grade
so in the same breath in the same answer
she has two different conflicting
narratives about this law
and she's hoping that everybody is too
stupid to notice and unfortunately the
fact is that at least half of the
country or almost half really is too
stupid to notice
or too distracted to notice at any rate
um okay one other thing before we move
on i gotta i gotta play this for you two
just because this is another one of
those situations where i was subjected
to it and now i have to you know i have
to spread the misery around because
misery loves company and here is um
someone who describes themselves as a an
actor and a comedian you wouldn't really
know from this but this is a video that
went viral of his own
musical protest against the bill let's
all
suffer through this together
gosh i'd hate to upset your republican
peers so let me say the soft so no one
hears
i've
always
been
here's an interesting fact
oops i said it i'm gay
you can bet it's a badge that i wear
with a fabulous flower cause i'm kkk
yeah we know but we we know you don't
need to
that's one thing i love about about so
many of these things people are coming
out shouting i'm gay like okay well no
one no one ever said you can't say that
also you know we all we know
but thank you for announcing it in any
case all right here's an update on the
story from yesterday the uh the story we
led the show with yesterday an important
story that's being
largely ignored certainly by by mass
media even a lot of conservative media
isn't uh giving this the attention it
needs and deserves
but the daily wire has the update the
washington dc medical examiner said that
it will not be performing autopsies on
bodies of aborted babies that were
turned into police last week probably
pro-life activists and medical
professionals say that the bodies show
signs of illegal and gruesome abortion
procedures and these activists fear that
the bodies will be incinerated before
proper autopsies can be
conducted live action's director of
government affairs told the daily wire
on monday
one of the worst injustices would be if
the medical examiner and d.c government
dispose or incinerate the bodies of
these children before a full autopsy can
be completed
he said quote the abortionists do not
want autopsies performed because they
may indicate violations of federal law
dc must preserve these remains until a
full fair and thorough investigation can
can be completed now to remind you about
the story
this is
a
pro-life group i forget the name of it
the progress the progressive
anti-abortion uprising group um one of
the members of that group obtained
the bodies of
five children who are victims of
abortion and obtain these bodies from a
whistleblower apparently within the
clinic
and according to that whistleblower
these babies were killed in illegal
procedures whether it's partial birth
abortion which is supposedly illegal or
even there's evidence
that you can plainly see if you see the
pictures um as many people did as as
over the weekend
the kind of pictures that are seared
into your mind forever and you never
forget
but you can plainly see the evidence
that even
potentially
this these were abortions that occurred
after birth
now by the way the distinction between
a partial birth abortion and an after
birth abortion a post-birth abortion are
semantics at best
partial birth abortion the baby is being
killed
as he emerges from the birth canal like
part of his body
is out of the birth canal
and then um his skull is crushed or or
you know
something
basically a vacuum is
is
stuck into his skull and his brains are
sucked out of his body that's that's how
these procedures are carried out that's
the reality of it um so that's partial
birth
which was legal in this country for a
long time now it's supposedly illegal
and then after birth abortion or post
birth abortion is infanticide in other
words is just wait for the baby to fully
emerge and then kill it there's no
moral distinction at all between the two
um there's no medical distinction or
physical distinction either certainly no
scientific distinction
so there's evidence that this is what
happened to these um babies
the police
once the pro-life group obtained
the bodies of these victims they
contacted the police and said
we come come pick them up
and so far the police are saying we're
not going to investigate which like we
talked about yesterday
whether we're talking about abortion
victims or anything else you're given
the bodies of five dead people
wouldn't you want to do an autopsy to
figure out how they died
isn't that the first thing you would do
well not according to the police anyway
here's executive assistant chief of
police sean benedict
explaining that um
although they were just made aware of
these victims
they still have just decided already
that everything is fine and there's
really nothing to investigate listen
um in regards to the house that was
found with numerous fetuses today can
you confirm if that is the home of
lauren handys and do you have any idea
on how uh those fetuses got there and if
you all have been working with other
authorities across the country sure so
there's there's a couple of there's two
different things going on here
um miss handy is uh been indicted on a
federal investigation led by the fbi
that mpd was not a part of um so that's
number one the second piece is that we
were led to that uh house that you
mentioned
we did recover items that were
these are preliminary results ocme
looked took a look at those items they
are have been confirmed as fetuses
what we're seeing now is they those
fetuses were aborted in accordance with
dc law so we are not investigating
this incident along those lines doesn't
speak anything criminal in nature right
now about that
except for how they got into this house
and so we'll continue to look at that
are you working with authorities in
other states with how they got here to
the dc area
this is very early on and i think the
fbi's case may touch on interstate but
at this point we're we're about a day
into this
i don't know if that doesn't make your
blood boil um
then
you have no soul
he's
referring to
dead children dead babies as items
he says oh we obtained the items
well i ask you would he ever talk about
um
you know the victims of a
car crash or a mass shooting if there's
a mass shooting at a
mall somewhere
and he's talking about recovering the
bodies what he'd say oh yeah well we
obtained 15 items
that's how he's talking about these
children because he does not recognize
the children as being human beings he
doesn't recognize them as people
and as far as he's concerned even though
you have ted
you have five children
who have been brutally killed
um
for him the only crime worth
investigating is not how they were
killed
but how they ended up how they were
discovered the crime is in the
discovering of the crime
pretty common theme when it comes to the
abortion industry like we talked about
yesterday it's the same thing the center
center for medical progress
when they conducted an undercover
investigation
and revealed that planned parenthood was
chopping up babies and harvesting their
organs and selling them for parts like
an old vehicle or something you know
um
and the crime there
was not that this was happening it's
that the center for medical progress
found out about it so they're the
criminals
talk about shooting the messenger almost
in a literal sort of way
um
and he's just decided that we're not
even going to look into it
all they did
well they haven't done an autopsy
so this was just sort of the naked eye
test they they looked at the bodies and
said no illegal abortion there is no way
to know that they cannot possibly know
it
no it's quite the opposite they fear
they're afraid
that there was something illegal that
happened and that if they do the autopsy
they'll discover it and they will have
to prosecute
um
a prominent abortionist in the city
which they refuse to do
because the abortion industry is
basically a quasi-governmental agency at
this point these are it is protected by
the government and funded by the
government as if it is the government as
if it's part of the government
and the only the only hazard in this
conversation and we should be calling
this is something i mean all
conservatives i don't care if you're
conservative just if you're a decent
person
you should be demanding that this is at
least investigate there is no reason why
you wouldn't do an autopsy
well you just don't feel like it you got
better things to do
you don't have time
the only reason to do it is that you are
blatantly trying to cover up a crime
and every decent person should be
demanding that that doesn't happen
the only hazard in this conversation is
that it obscures the point
that even if these were quote legal
abortions it's still a horrific crime
maybe not according to the law books but
that's because the law books themselves
are twisted
and the law books need to be changed
so there's a crime at least a horrific
moral crime that occurred one way or
another
but either way there needs to be an
investigation
is uh
i don't know how i'm still shocked by
this kind of thing somehow
just that they could be so out in the
open about it you might as well hold a
press conference and just say to the
press that hey listen we don't
we're not interested in prosecuting
abortionists here that's not what we do
so whatever he did
not we're not looking you might as well
say that
they have all but said that
all right let's move to this i don't
even know how to set this up exactly but
uh
so i won't let's just listen to
the latest from joe biden
when i was a young senator i was
thinking there was a guy who
ran steel from deemer steele out to ohio
and so i decided to ride out with him
see what it was like on the strike and i
was driving going through shiloh ohio
and uh and he he was his handle was big
ten
and remember everybody all the truck
stops were being blockaded at the time
during the strike
and he uh he called he said big ten
wanting to come in i forget exactly how
he said it and the and the only woman
truck driver ever knew i met that day
she said this is big mama no room
swear to god true story yes uh big mama
had corn pop sitting in the in the
passenger seat
i you know i thought before i played
that clip i should look into it to find
out the context because i'm i'm
totally mystified by it i have no idea
what the context was
uh but it it actually doesn't matter the
context i think we've learned that by
now about biden that there's no context
that can make any of this make any sense
so we've got corn pop we've got big mama
look
this is a this is a a man
who should be sitting on a porch
somewhere in a rocking chair
telling stories
that's all he really wants to do anyway
and so he should be sitting on a that's
where he belongs is like sitting on a
porch in a rocking chair telling stories
and all his grandkids are listening and
saying did that actually happen and you
know because like half
the stories are 90 not true whether he's
lying or he just forgets what what
happened in the past because his mind is
failing him but that's that is the
proper context for this man
not running
the free world
so every time you see one of those
videos it's always one of those moments
where you you laugh because it's funny
and then
the laughter soon fades away into sheer
terror because you realize that oh like
this guy is he's not on a
porch in a rocking chair he's actually
in charge of the country
and he has no clue what's going on
currently
and the second option aside from him is
kamela harris who is only slightly more
cognizant than he is
that's the position we put ourselves in
all right one more thing this is from
the daily wire it says
not even it's not even june yet and
already corporations are signaling their
allegiance to the progressive lgbt
agenda the latest seemingly unaffiliated
brand to come out in support of the
cause is none other than oreo cookie
which has been owned by the
multinational food and beverage
conglomerate mandel is international
since 2012.
um the marketing team at oreo
couldn't wait until pride month to put
out a new commercial spot which featured
a young man coming out as gay to his
grandmother this is an oreo ad first of
all before we play this ad
or a little bit of it uh as mentioned in
the article like you you
we're a couple months away from pride
month
and it gets more extravagant with each
passing year but
especially with what's happening in
florida and everything else you cannot
even imagine
the sheer intensity
of the virtue signaling that we are
about to experience once we get to pride
month it is going to be like unlike
anything i don't know if any of us will
survive the month without cringing to
death because what we're about to play
here with this oreo ad
this is oh this is just an appetizer
um so let's play a little bit of this go
ahead
okay well the ad is not in english
either so this doesn't really translate
for an audio podcast but
all i can tell you is i watch the ad and
it's like it's like 75 minutes long
and
the oreos appear in it one time
okay this is all about so this this guy
he's gonna he's gonna come out of the
closet to his grandmother
uh there's the oreo so the oreo does
make an appearance
right before he's about to come out of
the closet they take some oreos
and then his grandmother comes in okay
all right we've seen enough of that
[Music]
you know i could almost all right i
don't even want to see it turn it off um
i could almost
i'm not going to say respected
but i would be somewhat impressed with
all these virtue signaling lgbt ads if
you could find a way
within the ad to tie it back to the
product like that would be
impressive i'd actually watch the ad
just to see like how do you get there
how do you bring this back to
advertising for a cookie
but they don't even bother to do that
anymore
this is it seems like a small thing but
just the fact that um
every major conglomerate every major
corporation in america
are tripping over themselves i mean
they're they're even discarding their
own messaging
forget about forget about advertising
their product
the primary point of this ad this is a
very this is a very new thing because it
used to be that
yeah advertisers they would seize on
social issues and that kind of thing to
sell their product but the primary
message in the advertisement was always
about the product it was it always came
back to buy my product
you know pepsi and coca-cola do this
kind of thing all the time about hey
teach the world to sing and it's a peace
and harmony but
how do you
bring peace and harmony to the world
it's by it's by drinking pepsi or
coca-cola whatever that ad was
now they've gotten rid of that the ad is
not even about the product
the ad is simply to affirm their
allegiance to the lgbt cause
and that is when you know you have power
in the culture that's when you know you
have privilege
when you have major corporations who are
even
discarding their concerns for the bottom
line and profiting for the sake of
[Music]
bending the knee to you
that's proof
well if you've been listening to my show
for a while you know that i've been an
activist against the lazy grocery
shoppers who don't don't put their
grocery carts away i have some
unfortunate news the grocery carts
attacked me in my own car
this is a very real story not just
something i'm saying
for the purposes of this ad
unfortunately when i was pulling out of
my parking spot a road grocery cart
crashed into my car leaving my front
bumper scratched and more importantly
leaving me emotionally traumatized by
this event there are two lessons we
could take away from this one don't be
lazy and put your shopping carts away so
i don't have to suffer and two you could
solve an issue like mine quickly and
without breaking the bank by just
visiting rockauto.com they have touch-up
paint and pens that are as easy to use
as a magic marker rockauto.com is an
online family-owned business that sells
all the auto parts you could ever
possibly need that are specific to your
own vehicle their prices are shockingly
reasonable and their shopping is quick
and also their shipping is quick so no
matter what um it happens to be going on
with your car you can trust rock auto to
get what you need fast rock auto has a
very user friendly website they can make
it very easy for you to pick the right
car parts for your car you'll see photo
specs and even installation tips so you
can feel confident that you're choosing
the correct parts for your vehicle so
what are you waiting for go to
rockauto.com for your auto parts needs
today and write walsh in their how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i'm the one that sent you that's
rockauto.com to shop for your auto parts
today
okay let's get to the comment section do
you know their name
all right um
brayden says matt you said you would
quit if the daily wire bought the rights
to veggietales i laughed so hard when dw
announced that they hired the
veggietales guys to make children's
content for you
now
this is the claim that braden made is
that i i had previously announced that
if we bought the right that if we bought
veggietales i would quit and resign from
the daily wire um i don't know remember
that exactly but i think we have the
clip let's go back and uh
and just do a fact check on this
major tom fisher says was thinking about
the question about daily wire's future
movies and now i really want to see dw
buy big idea back from dreamworks and
finally bring back veggietales
bringing it back to its home in
tennessee too
i tell you right now if daily wire buys
veggie tails i quit
i want no part of that
all right so you see there
technically
i i did say that if that if that if we
yes it's great if we get into children's
entertainment
but if we
purchase veggie tails and i'll resign
from the daily wire
but technically we did not purchase
veggie tails what we did is we hired the
guys who wrote veggie tales
so
that's the distinction and i think it's
an important distinction
and it's look it's nothing against
veggie tales itself let me let me
clarify something here okay
uh it's it's not a problem with
vegetables it's just that you have to
understand as a
as a christian child of the 90s the
veggietales were
inescapable so everywhere you went you
were haunted by
cucumbers and broccoli singing to you
about jesus christ and so after a while
it just kind of you can never look at
salads the same way again and it just it
it has this effect on you and so that's
what i'm traumatized by that
that's the way i'm justifying it anyway
you're not getting rid of me so easily
janelle camp says you're right matt a
friend told me last week that he found
out they've put a litter box in the
girls restroom at the local public
school this is happening in a small town
in illinois because one of the kids
identifies as a cat i can't imagine who
cleans it the student so insane
yes uh
you might hear this and you know this is
just someone this is a youtube comment
uh this can't really be happening this
is 100
happening
in fact there are
libs of tick tock on twitter recently i
just recently had an image of this like
an actual litter box
in a public school restroom
for students who identify as cats this
is really happening that is a thing that
is happening in our schools now
that is how broken the schools are
that is how deep the
intentionally cultivated and fostered
identity crisis has become for kids
um
let's see what else do we got
jaylin says when matt said that
mcdonald's fries are the worst i out
loud gasped and said matthew
well i mean they are like i said it used
to be that they were i'd put them in the
top five but recently there's no effort
that goes into it anymore with
mcdonald's with their product with their
service anything they just
you you sit in line at the drive-through
and even if there's just two cars in
front of you you're gonna be in line for
45 minutes
and then you pull up and they just throw
the food at you and it's like they
didn't even bother to cook it half the
time no effort zero effort arby's on the
other hand they put real effort into
their product and especially into the
french fries
um
let's see
another comment says my cousin who's
pretty conservative and based has been
dating a girl who just started working
at an abortion clinic as a social worker
she doesn't need the money as her family
is well off and she's and she is
somewhat well off as well
told him that if she won't quit he needs
to end the relationship as it will never
be anything but miserable
plus all the feminist gender theory
stuff that goes along with that crowd is
extra poisonous on top
his girlfriend actually is pretty cool
and a kind person for the most part but
seems like the new job is a deal breaker
was i too harsh or forward with him
separate from not biting my tongue could
i be incorrect on my in my take on
things
uh no not not at all
especially in a dating relationship
um
you know
there's
no reason at all that this is this is
this is an easy one
you're not committed to the person
you're not married
they're advertising ahead of time this
is an important point too even leaving
aside the fact that she's working at an
abortion clinic that's obvious you're
working at an abortion clinic this is
not this is not so this is not wife
material this is not someone you can
have a relationship with
um because for one thing
you have to be able to you can have
differences and they say opposites
attract
but when opposites attract that's that's
referring more to personality my wife
and i have
diametrically
opposite personalities
but your fundamental beliefs and values
and principles and goals in life the
things that you cherish most
you cannot be opposites on that
that's exactly where you have to connect
that's where the relationship is formed
that's where it's maintained
and so if you have a girlfriend that
works at an abortion clinic and you're
pro-life that clearly tells you that you
are
on you could not be further apart in
terms of your fundamental values right
and even if you didn't work at an
abortion clinic
if you're dating someone who's
pro-abortion
who just has pro-abortion views that is
also a deal-breaker
and there are a lot of reasons for that
one that i just described but also you
have to think about this i mean
if eventually you get married and you
have kids
if someone's pro-abortion then you know
that it's at least in their mind
a possibility it's at least an option
to kill your child in the womb
and that's simply a risk you can't take
um
you need to be able to trust
your spouse
with your child trust that your your
child will be safe with your spouse
the worst thing in the world i mean
really the worst
is to be married to someone who you feel
like you cannot trust
especially with your children
um
and
finally if i could find it uh tie my
shoe says matt are you going to narrate
your own audio book this time or
continue to be lazy edit just realized
he'll call me lazy for not reading the
physical book
well you took the words right out of my
mouth but if you are lazy yes i am
narrating uh the audio book
uh in this case and the book we're
referring to of course is what is a
woman which you can go and pre-order on
amazon or at whatiswoman.com there's the
plug let's get to our daily cancellation
well you know i don't think it could be
more clear that the world has descended
into absolute degeneracy so there's
never been a better time to renew your
faith in god that's why i'm extremely
excited to announce that today is the
release of andrew clavin's latest book
the truth and beauty after years of
studying the gospels and trying to find
the true meaning of jesus's words clavin
is ready to share what he has found it's
for anyone who's striving for a belief
in a materialistic world and i could not
recommend it enough it's a beautiful
book in keeping with the title head to
amazon and order your copy of the truth
and beauty today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel madonna
who is 63 years old less than a decade
away from her 70th birthday and yet
utterly determined to pretend that she
hasn't aged a day since she turned 22.
um these efforts have proven futile as
recently demonstrated by a tick tock she
posted because she's posting tick tocks
at 63. i'm 35 and too old for tick-tock
she's my mom's age and yet using the
platform her latest offering shows her
kind of mugging for the camera
leaning in uncomfortably close and
pouting her lips and what we can only
assume is some sort of attempt to be
i don't know sexually alluring
unfortunately madonna has had so much
plastic surgery in botox
that she now resembles some sort of
tropical lizard or perhaps she looks
like somebody who's suffering a severe
allergic reaction
and i'm not body shaming her when i say
that on the contrary the parts of her
body that i'm shaming are the parts that
are not her body at all
tragically the parts of her body that
are not her body are at this point her
entire body
because she would rather look like a
non-human than simply looking like an
older human
and that's the first point that madonna
inadvertently raises for us
she might be an extreme example of this
phenomenon but she's hardly the only
example plastic surgery is increasingly
popular in our culture with rates of the
procedure increasing by some 25 percent
over the past couple of decades now i'm
not arguing
against plastic surgery in principle i
think the procedure can be worthwhile
certainly justifiable in cases where
somebody is suffering from a horrible
disfigurement of some kind of burn
victim for example
but age itself is not a disfigurement
it's not a disease it's not shameful
it's not ugly
now we've grown accustomed to treating
age this way in our culture
the the completely ridiculous rule of
modern etiquette which says that it's
rude to ask somebody their age kind of
plays into this mentality i mean why
shouldn't i ask somebody how old they
are why is it embarrassing to have lived
on the planet for longer than others far
from embarrassing most societies
throughout history have seen advanced
age as a badge of honor
older people were the village elders
they were wise counselors you turn to
them for sage advice which is informed
by their years of experience on earth
old people were storytellers
um
like joe biden with big mama and corn
pop
they were the keepers of uh not only
wisdom but your culture's past
they were respected and honored
they kept you connected to your past
because they lived through it
now there are many cultures around the
world today that still treat the elderly
this way
go to any of these places and you'll
never hear somebody declare that they're
70 years young
no they're 70 years old emphasis on old
because
there is value and beauty
and wisdom in being old
we have the opposite attitude here we
don't honor old age anymore
we don't want to see it you know we
usher old people off to the nursing
homes
and then if you're in new york you send
in covet patients after them
part of the shift may be explained by
the fact that modern medicine has made
it so that we no longer see it as any
sort of special achievement to reach old
age most of us get there no matter how
we've lived
but i think more than that we are
shallow and superficial
and so we value the most frivolous
aspects of youth
more than we value the deepest benefits
of old age
adding to the trouble we also hate
everything that is old this includes art
music architect texture human beings
themselves
because our culture is at war with its
own past
and has determined that everything and
everyone who existed prior to 30 years
ago was an ignorant racist savage
but perhaps most saliently of all
i think we fear our own mortality an old
age is a reminder of mortality
as the old are perceived as being closer
to death than the young now this is a
false perception
because the veil separating us from this
life and the next is thin and fragile
for everyone
and death follows us all around
everywhere whether we like it or not
this is how we see it
and so we treat old age like a curse
a shame something to be hidden we don't
want to look at it
many older people themselves have
adopted this attitude in fact people in
the donna's generation helped to foster
this attitude in our culture to begin
with
and so
she not only carves up her own body
trying to tear away the old flesh like
there's a younger version of herself
hiding underneath it but she also
conducts herself and acts like she's a
teenage tick tocker instead of a
grandmother
the results are bizarre and often quite
unsightly
and pathetic
which is why
i implore older people
i beseech them with this
if you're old just be old
look old you aren't gonna fool anybody
and why should you try just be who you
are be what you are
there is dignity in that
there is no dignity in whatever the hell
madonna has become
and that's why she is today finally
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less join me and my co-host
georgia hal for daily coverage of all
the biggest stories on morning wire